[موسيقى]
بدايه خلينا نتعرف على عمليه الايض او ما
يسمى بالميك هي عمليه حيويه يقوم بها
الجسم لحتى يامن الطاقه الضروريه للخلايا
بتقوم بوظائفها الحيويه فخلال اول ثمان
ساعات النصف صيام الجسم راح يستفيد من
السكر او الجلوكوز يتم امتصاصه من اخر
وجبه تم تناولها فيما بعد ذلك راح يتوجه
للبلايكوجين هي مخازن السكر موجوده بالكبد
او العضلات وبعد 12 ساعه من الصيام الجسم
راح يتوجه للدهون راح تكون هي مصدر الطاقه
الوحيده فحيتم حرق هاي الدهون للاستفاده
منها وبالتالي هذا بساعد على نقصان الوزن
[موسيقى]
احنا بننصح الناس بشهر رمضان بشرب كميات
كافيه من السوائل عدم تناول كميات كبيره
من الطعام خلال وجبه الافطار واكيد تناول
كميات كافيه من الخضار والفواكه
وممارسه بعض التمرينات الرياضيه الخفيفه
بعد وجبه الافطار
[موسيقى]